Chris Pratt reveals the best love advice
he's ever received I've heard some
people say don't go to bed mad
I think that's garbage the actor and his
wife Anna Faris pretty much defined
relationship goals so it's no shock that
he's got some wise words when it comes
to romance sometimes you got to go to
bed mad but at least touch the toes at
least just touch toes and I know we'll
deal with it later I didn't get some
sleep
touch toes et spoke with Pratt on Monday
in New York City at the premiere of his
new Western action film The Magnificent
Seven I had just ordered a drink from
that man Brad is undeniably on a career
hot streak in December he'll star
opposite Jennifer Lawrence in
passenger's a role Scott Eastwood
recently revealed he auditioned for but
lost to Pratt still though Pratt says he
can totally relate oh my gosh there's so
many roles that I've lost out to other
actresses as far as dealing and you find
out that a lot of times that's the way
it's meant to be you know there's a
divine plan that we're all following and
and I believe in and you know you find
out when you don't get something it
turns out that that was actually a good
thing if something else happens